بعيدا عن جراحات التكميم وضع لهنات المعده
قد تكون الطريقه التي سنعرضها اليوم ابسط
واسهل سواء لخساره الوزن او فتح الشهيه
ايضا
على كل حال هي ليست الا حبه الكترونيه يتم
بلعها لتعديل مستويات الجوع والتحكم به
تقوم بالتحفيز الكهربائي بتكهربنا يعني
لمده 20 دقيقه ثم التخلص منها في غضون
اسبوعين تقريبا بحسب التجارب الاوليه
الكبسوله الكهربائيه التي طورها فريق من
الباحثين من جامعه نيويورك ابوظبي طبعا
ومعهد مساء
للتكنولوجيا نجحت ايضا في التاثير على
هرمون الجرينينين في الجسم والتحكم في
الشهيه ويسعى طريق الفريق بمشاهدينا البحث
الى استخدام التحفيز العصبي بهذه الحبه
الكهربائيه في علاج اضطرابات التغذيه
والاضطرابات العصبيه
والنفسيه ايضا
[موسيقى]